And now for the answer.
Indeed, I gave a hint right within the story.
"Battery" is the correct answer.
After 3 hours, my battery had run out.
Which means that until then, I had worked on battery power.
In order to recharge my battery, I reconnected to AC power.
And it turned out that it was this difference that caused the program to fail.
When my laptop ran on AC power, which was precisely the configuration
with which everything was installed,
the program worked just fine.
If it ran on a battery, however, the program failed.
It turned out that my laptop ran slower when running on batteries.
This saved energy, but also introduced interesting timeout errors.
So I made a mental note to fix this as soon as we got home,
and of course, I gave the demo on AC power
to make sure that all our tests were not in vain.